ashley is with us in florida hi Ashley
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi Dave
Ramsey the pleasure to talk to you you
too what's up so I'm actually a new
listener and I've learned a lot from you
the last two or three weeks and my
fiance and I just finished paying our
car loans but we still have his student
loan which is about 22,000 and we're
debating whether we should pay that off
or just way for the law enforcement
officer student loan forgiveness which
she has another seven years to get that
paid off okay there's not a we until
you're married you should not be paying
you should not be paying bills that have
his name on them until you're married
okay you're gonna get yourself in a
pinch don't do that when are you getting
married in six months in February rate
okay he can pay on his student loans
until then and after that we can pay on
them what's the balance on a student
loan it's 22 oh I definitely would knock
that out
I wouldn't let $22,000 hang around for
seven freaking years and hope something
goes right no I'm getting out of there
let's get that thing done as fast as
y'all can let him work on it really hard
until you get married if you want to
save up a bunch of money until you get
married you can throw it at it after the
honeymoon then can catch up what you
would have paid in other words before
then that's fine but do not pay other
people's bills until there is an
official ring on your finger and I'm not
talking about the engagement ring so be
careful with that I have talked to the
fiance after the other one was killed in
a car wreck and the mother-in-law-to-be
hates her and she paid off $40,000 of
his debt and she'll never see that money
and the mother-in-law got the life
insurance I've had that phone call I've
had that counseling session multiple
times I've talked to the jilted lover
the runaway bride
ended up not getting married to who they
thought was their soulmate and knew they
just knew deep down it was all gonna
work out the way it's supposed to in
Cinderella but it didn't
the glass slipper didn't fit and he or
she has paid off the other ones debt and
never sees that money again much less
their former lover again so it's not
that I'm not romantic it's not that I
don't think you're gonna get married
it's not that I'm an old grouch it's
that I have seen the other side of this
crap when you do it wrong people those
of you out there that are shacking up
you're not married you're just got
roommate itis don't be paying each
other's debts you don't pay your
roommates debts
it's relationally stupid it's
financially stupid and it's legally
stupid you got almost no way to recover
in these situations please if you're
getting married in six months getting
married in a year getting married in
eight months just pile up the money and
after the honeymoon throw the money at
the debt but do not pay someone else's
debt I've seen all the downsides I don't
want that to happen to you people I love
you people I want you to win I'm here to
help you I'm not joking around I've been
doing this a while I got socks older
than most of you